the border wall is once again taking
center stage as we just said
and president trump isn't waiting on
congress to keep moving forward on
building it
fisher sand and gravel company is one of
four companies selected to build the
cement prototype
and the ceo tommy fisher joins us now
with more tommy
uh you have designed a big big
wall i i've seen some pictures of it um
it's one of four prototypes the lack of
funding is there from congress
give us a sense how big is that wall
that we're looking at a picture of right
now
yeah ours is ours is a wall not a
see-through fence
it's an actual wall it's 30 feet tall 30
inches thick of concrete
and it will work and one of the things
jason listening to the last
viewer we put a proposal on
department of homeland security's desk
to build 700 miles in roughly five
years through california new mexico and
arizona
complete with high-speed roads for the
agents that will actually work for 10.77
billion backed by a bond there's no cost
overruns
we're here to do exactly what we came to
as deliver
border security for every single
american and we can prove it works
now their terrain is not all flat you've
got places with river beds you have some
mountainous areas particularly in new
mexico
so what do you do on those portions of
it is the wall
for the entire span or what do you do
about those mountain areas
absolutely no exceptions for mountains
with our patented system we do step
footings on the bottom we keep a
consistent
um top we can go up 17 grades and build
the roads that the agents can
and furthermore i i included a smaller
proposal to build
15 miles in one year so that current
fence that they're building right now in
calexico
the government has given two basically
300 days to build two miles
with one crew we can build 15 miles so
the difference is is we're building a
wall not a
fence president trump had it right
congress did not do him justice by
basically limiting
the only thing they could spend is on a
fence not
a wall imagine if general mattis got in
the military budget 700 billion but
there was a caveat on that you could
only build old military options that
doesn't work
and the the basically the fence
basically wears out in
30 years best case scenario i've got
places where it rusted
in basically 10 years so our point is
what about the point though some people
have said look you build a wall we're
just going to build a tunnel
and and they're really our intelligence
and being able to detect a tunnel what
do we do then how
how far down into the ground for
instance does that wall go
well it goes six feet but we have ways
that if you cover up with our spread
footing where our footings work
you can track tunnels to within maybe
two or three feet
of variability and when i put two
high-speed access roads on both sides of
the wall
you have views both ways so basically if
they did build the tunnel we could pull
right up on our road
just like you'd fill an old coal pit or
anything else you could um
basically auger down and fill it full of
ground have you had people try to go up
and over it
i mean are people able to go up and over
it no because we're going to just think
about this jason you're going to have an
access road for the border patrol agents
that's sitting
40 feet off the border right now that
they're on a paved road that the agents
can't be detected so you want to put up
a ladder where an agent can drive right
up on you that'd be like you asking to
put up a ladder on a highway
and the border agents are coming every
couple minutes so when we build what we
can build
literally those agents can travel six to
ten times as fast as they do because
they have access
in the end you have to build a barrier
and our barrier lasts 150 years
but then we got to give access to these
agents so they can protect every one of
our lives
well listen uh it's a it's an
interesting prototype i know there are
three others that have also gotten an
approved
prototype in place but i do think that
personally i think the president's right
you do need a wall because it works and
we anything we do to help our border
patrol agents do their job
because of the influx is the right thing
so thank you again sir for being here